so many people have read untamed
especially people that i know
and they found inspiration but for
people not familiar
what is it about what would you say if
you had to give a synopsis
well the storyline the main storyline
going through it is when i was i was in
a broken marriage to a good man
and that is a hard place for a woman to
be because we're supposed to be grateful
for what we have and good enough is
supposed to be good enough
um but uh as that
marriage as we were struggling to kind
of find some unbrokenness i fell madly
in love with a woman
and um i don't know when i met her this
part of me
rose up that i had abandoned a long time
ago and i just was faced with this
kind of life or death situation it felt
like like am i going to abandon this
self
um because i'm too afraid to rock the
boat of my life
or am i going to abandon everyone else's
expectations of me
and honor myself for the first time in
my life yeah i love alicia's freaking
out right now i don't know if you can
see her
and you did you did you honor me you did
me time
seven that's one of her new songs
yes i did glennon you you write about
the public fallout from your divorce i'm
obviously going through one right now
um it's horrible there are so many hard
parts
um my the hardest for me is the kids
that's the hardest for me um you know i
always i think as women especially were
trained alicia and i were talking
earlier
to take it all on and you can deal with
it and you're fine but it's your babies
that you worry about so what
what was the hardest part because you
also did it publicly
um you know that's a hard thing as well
what was the hardest part getting
through all of that
yeah so i think no matter how public
things are the hardest part of divorce
is
is always the kids right um we're
trained to believe that what we have to
avoid at all costs is a broken family
and that a broken family is a divorce
what i came to believe is this um i
stayed in a broken marriage for a long
time for my children and one day i was
looking at my daughter and i thought oh
my god i am staying in this marriage for
her but would i
want this marriage for her and if i
would not want this marriage for her
then why am i modeling bad love and
calling that good mothering
right yes and the reason is because
we've all been trained to believe
that a good mother is a martyr right
that what a mother does
is just slowly dies right hides her
ambition and buries her feelings and
buries her sexuality and her dreams in
in honor of her children and we know
that that's the worst legacy we can pass
on to our kids which is why carl jung
said there is no
greater burden on a child than the
unlived life of a parent
yeah not a divorce the unlived life of a
parent so
you know i didn't leave a bad marriage
in spite of being a mother i left
because i'm a good mother
right and because a good mother is a
model is a model not a martyr
well and i it's so interesting that you
brought that line
that's the book that's my favorite in
your book that's my favorite line from
it because
and and not to put this on you it was
just one of those things that was that
thing i needed to see
to make a step in my life and not just
for me but also for
my current husband i'm like this isn't
happiness you know for both of us you
know like i feel
both of us deserve better and neither
one of us would want this for our
children and it was like
reading that line like so hit home for
me
and not selfishly but for the family
it's like well i don't want this for
anyone
in in this scenario right now and it was
just such a
powerful piece of knowledge that seems
so
logical but it's never been worded like
that to me so i mean thank you so much
um it it you really i said this in the
break before you came on but you
i know you get this because you get so
many people just raving about you and
probably in tears saying thank you so
much and you've changed their lives and
and and everything but it is such a
superpower that you have to be able to
help lead others to theirs and and and
it's just it's a beautiful thing you do
but i want to come back to you too
alicia because i know i stole glennon
for like a good
solid 30 just then um but i want to know
i want to know what's what's your
biggest takeaway from the book untamed
i'm just curious what was
the thing that stuck out for me is what
i talked about is there anything that
really stuck out to you that helped
i just really love this energy this
reminder
this this this untamed
this word is so good
you know what i mean this this concept
and this word about being completely
unbounded yeah you know there isn't
being the cheetah
that yes the joke that cheetah reference
at the beginning i
love it that's who you want to be you
want to be able to be completely
you know in your wind and you're sore in
your power
and i think we spend so much of our life
trying to figure out what that is
and that's okay there's not a rush
there's not a timeline on that
it happens when it happens for you but i
think being more
comfortable with words like untamed and
unbounded and
you know just completely free to be who
you are everything that she so elegantly
said
and do it because it's good for you and
therefore good for everyone around you
that theme just reminds me and reminds
me and reminds me and that's my favorite
part of what you're up to oh my gosh me
too and i love um i think
in the book too it's like you know it's
okay
like we end up taming ourselves and and
we did that because
to make people feel comfortable we were
supposed to find we're supposed to do
what we're supposed to do you know
the part we were given you know from
birth basically and i love
the fact that it's okay to feel
uncomfortable
like uncomfortable like a lot of
positive things come from being
uncomfortable a lot of change a lot of
talk a lot of
so i mean just that message i feel like
carries not just i know that a lot of
women relate to the book but i do feel
like a lot of men
can also really benefit from a lot of
these ideas i mean
even how you talk about men and what
they're conditioned or they're supposed
to be this and they're
you know and and you know erase their
femininity and it's just a really
great book and i and i really really
appreciate you and not just the books
that ted talks all the things you do
that i
that i get to go down the rabbit hole on
youtube and watch